at least the rain stopped for us what
we've got here
can I ask please that so we take the
emergency evacuation as when this race
of these presidents and I think they're
already normally the depending we have
known minutes of the meeting held on the
7th of November is ago we shall sign
them as a true record the other matters
arising from that not mentioned
elsewhere in the agenda any declarations
of interest please if there should be
any during the meeting that you
recognize please let us know make sure
they admitted so we are now on to item 6
which is the council project program
management office so go to that one
please Thank You chair the also I think
is self-explanatory so this report comes
quarterly - it's a committee and an
update on the - product which are
currently within its scope which is in
relation to the implementation and
effects of the measures taken as a
result of the homelessness reduction Act
and the contract with Ag so in relation
to the migration and Tweenies your crowd
the homelessness hosted production act I
think is it's self-explanatory and the
assistant director has provided a
commentary in the body of the report the
it's worth spending little bit at a time
though
the poetry in relation to the ICT
project the as it says within the report
the recent component failure has forced
us to reconsider our strategy in this
area simply because the migration
efforts of edgy serve have been somewhat
impacted by hardware failure on a site
which is our responsibility and not AG
serves so there's a piece of work which
is being planned in relation to
understanding the state of the existing
hardware and its longevity and how that
will then compare to the remaining
migration work that needs to be
undertaken by this council to complete
the full transition two years ago cloud
so as a consequence of that
ivar such a for the the project based
mind and for additional work streams to
be planned and plotted so that we can
see the interdependencies of the work
that needs to be done like various work
streams relating to particular
applications and their transition to the
cloud that work is due to commence if
indeed hasn't begun already and it's
intended to be reported in - back to
executive in the new year okay
please speak later Jim a couple of
questions if I might does the new
appraisal have a price tag on it because
I would assume that required extra
resource is that resource within
existing budget or is there going to be
a requirement for additional budget so
help to actually solve the problems that
we're having once and for all rather
than a dribble effect so the answer to
that is at this stage I don't know the
original strategy was to maintain the
status quo in the existing IT
architecture and infrastructure to
support a gradual and planned migration
the we have we need to have a health
check done on the existing
infrastructure to understand whether
there are items there that don't meet
our critical on things which they all
threaten the longevity of that that
hardware until that piece of work has
been done and I can't answer the
question is whether there is additional
cost there may be a business decision
that says in relation to migrating and
quicker than we had originally planned
that we may decide this and there's a
business reason for doing so that may
have a cost but that have been
cost-benefit analysis which we would do
it time and bring back to the sport so
at this stage I also think that quantity
of questions I didn't know
so if I may only go just if I could come
on that point on that point yet please
yeah dude you're not just it's a
clarification are you talking about the
question relates to the hardware on on
on site at RDC or AG so the question was
relating to the report that I've just
been heard I've just been hearing so
what I have been hearing is that certain
things are going to need to be done to
enable what we've been trying to do
there are some shortfalls underneath and
we're having to put it improve the
workflow as you said and that's that's
it will it entail additional cost your
suppose you don't know yet okay and and
secondly you you're looking to maybe
increase those door-y how can I put it
the right in which we actually are able
to transfer to the cloud I take it
that's the other item you are looking at
and so that again might take additional
resource which again I don't think you
have no idea what that additional
resource will be so my question was
actually when will we actually have that
come back to us so you know we can
actually see what is actually going on I
believe we need to solve this problem as
quickly as possible because the longer
it goes on it's most unsatisfactory and
a reputational consequence of not being
able to do the work properly so those
were the two items that I think are very
important Goodin that obviously need to
come back for us to look at we don't
completely yes okay
don't show ever Thank You chairman M
just one cushion and I'm asking this
because with my staff at home all the
staff being kept up to date as to what's
going on at all times
yes they are yes without phone because
I'm here indifferent well on the base is
that at any given point there are
probably only 50 to 60 percent of staff
on site so to the extent that Shaw
myself and assistant directors for the
floors with Challenger everybody if
people are off site when we are reliant
on my Manchester pops on information
the internet has been updated so there
is a message there for everybody to read
so there are some in some way
expectation is that the Cascade will
would have reached everybody okay so
it's been brought to my attention and so
those in the will to live with a
computer system at the moment quite
frankly we are however we look at
whether we called ourselves watch for
District Council or what we call
ourselves we are a business and we need
to provide a service and if a star
unhappy you know I have concerns and I'm
just like that mounted and I just need
to make sure or staff are fully aware
however it happens a days however I
don't care as long as they are as
important as as two members to
I said I think you're relying on
cascading information but if it's kind
of the trouble is you get a message but
I know you get a Chinese whispers
starting you know interviewed for the a
slightly different person yeah but at
least you know if you're putting
something else before everybody yeah
because about the time it reaches the
bottom of the line it yeah surely so
it's important to make sure that message
goes off side of it next please
two things just the time though the
concerns I mean what you've just said
describing how how has that told things
we must have a system that is effective
that allows staff to find out what you
wanted to know if if we put a system
that relies on this relies on that
relies on the other it's not good enough
it's not working there's an organization
we have to have a system that is
effective the tongue that allows us to
tell stuff what were you need them to
know whatever there's a circumstance
where over the time however however it's
done whatever methods it's got to be
effective and any provocation about
whether it whether something happens or
doesn't it isn't good enough in you know
a communication system for an
organisation like us so that's the the
first element I was I was content with
what you were saying about the ICT
project and and so on but there were
just two words that concern me and that
was investigate and find out now at this
point I was not under the impression
that investigating anything and finding
out anything would still be part of the
equation I thought that with the
migration from capita to enter serve
there was a huge amount of knowledge
gained again about our system with the
catastrophic failure not necessarily our
form through a combination of all sorts
of circumstances but with the
catastrophic failure like that it was
the problem for the most immediate
for a detailed investigation of what we
had where we were and what was our way
forward and I am concerned if at this
point we're still saying we need to
investigate because we've got to find
out or we don't know because that is a
vulnerability and I don't believe that
we can have an ICT vulnerability that is
unquantified after the experience we
went through which was yeah
further for the the council reputation
although we we got through it was
managed quite well it was a catastrophic
event honey it's not acceptable for that
to happen again
through lack of knowledge well I call
the catastrophic it means it's where we
Yoshi lose data which we didn't but
having said that I think the point is
it's about how quickly we migrate to the
cloud and you've got to make a bit of
business cases that's resolved I get
what you're saying and I get we're
saying as well because I think one of
the things we have to be careful of is
the robustness of the system that we got
and that indeed our staff we've realized
so much now or RT systems that's the way
the business is operating they can
actually have that reliability built
into where they're using and the
robustness
I don't know sometimes they were working
on a Monday morning and oh it's not
working on having yourself when I was a
long time ago when I was at work you
used to drive you bonkers but having
said that you know if we're putting
things in place that actually take that
up and I think as far as the hardware so
I think mines it within Roger if we're
looking for duplication and some of
those things I think we are as well and
again that could be a business case
going forward you know we need to make
sure that we've got that robustness
built in as best as we can
nothing's ever a huntress in
percent of these things but pretty
reliable over the years as we've had it
but it's the other thing you've gotta
consider is the amount of data that is
actually being handled by that system is
so much more now as well than I ever
used to me so you know that's so you put
I think one of the things you've got a
built-in is some capacity so make sure
that's there now whether that's within
the as you play out or I don't know but
it's something I know that you need to
look at sorry Shawn you wanted to come
behind me just I mean I just hope this
will reassure members I mean in terms of
the to hardware failures that we've
suffered in relationship first failure
we continue to have a duplicate switch
available and we have the correct
configuration for that switch so if that
didn't fail again it would be replaced
very quickly indeed with very little
impact on the cancel services so that
that is absolutely the situation with
that hardware failure attends the second
failure of the domain controller that
existed in the offices in Rochford
that's now working in the in the in the
cloud so you know that in terms of how
that in the future we've already dealt
with that issue I think in relation to
the issue of investigating find out I
think the key for me is around
understanding what else is in that back
room and what else we can put into into
the a zero client what needs to stay in
Rochford so it's more about
understanding that as an issue than
understanding
there's something else in there that is
going to be it's going to be an issue
for us but I think you've got the three
other you've got the three year servers
that are going to be managed by third
parties haven't you as well so they're
going to go to third parties and the
only thing I would say there is that you
know can we be reassured that those
third parties are actually having the
same sort of look at the robustness of
their systems so we you know we know
that we can rely as a supplier but we
had a contract relating to our emails
didn't me that we weren't aware of the
fact it was coming to an end because we
changed to ng something so let's just
make sure all that side of it as well as
in place to make sure is it's a robust
sorry it was no three yeah I'd had a
conversation with you George previously
about this item you know it was just
with regard to if there is extra
resource needed and you know you're
trying to move all the users instantly
as yo gladly because that will obviously
make it more efficient for us all that's
everybody
I asked George to give me an idea as to
when I'm not going to hold you to this
George but he was in the hunt I guess
you're looking at February is that
correct
it's around February ok so will mean
obviously you know we're gonna if that
is the case and the resources are needed
to make sure that that is going to be
delivered in February
as huge has you know ascertained that
would be very useful for everybody to
know that your they are working to a
timeline that is actually fun and the
other thing was a concern again I
mentioned to George was what was a
simple fact on the telephony now again a
backup for that if that goes wrong but
now I know that you believe things like
whatsapp and things like this just don't
see any way but I think again I would
believe that in the cloud of various
laws you've got to get the format
selected and if things go wrong with
communications but I'm just I just want
to know have you brought backup plan
please and all the rest in regards to
anything that in future that we've
encountered terminal could I just say I
have things in leash that it clearly has
always been the intention that all staff
will will go on to 365 you know and I
think the view is that we need to get
that project completed as quickly as we
can there are nothing February is the
it's a half step in the corridor there's
a second one being migrated to t65 so
you know the thing is is is is rolling
rolling along I think the comment about
telephony is a really interesting one
and one of the things that we're doing
on the 21st of December is having a bit
of a short keys in the office to
highlight to you know staff exactly what
the facilities the 365 will bring and
one of the things we've asked they
deserve to including that is escape for
business and my view on Skype for
business is that we would ultimately I
think you know we need to ditch the sort
of old stale telephony
got in the council and we need to go
electronic you know as many
organizations have already have already
done so I mean I think that would be my
ambition for the some points in the
future
in the meantime it seems to me that
there is an opportunity to actually
deliver us of some new opportunities and
resilience
by looking at ruling out that that sort
of that's a facility to you know a
number of staff pretty quickly so it
might be you know the leadership team
and members and so on um whatever but
you know I think I think we need to we
need to we need to look at that so I
think it's a good it's a well that's a
well meet point and the facilities are
there in the in the system to enabled us
to do that more discussions with angel
Erin thorn angel one with regard to ICT
yes we did go through a period of time
where it was out of our control and a
lot of the the last problem was an edgy
subpart from the hardware issues in that
RDC the fall over to the cloud server
did not happen because the settings
weren't set up correctly for major
serves or just review now it's that's
not our DC's responsibility that said
you serve that was corrected and we
actually switched over appropriately and
now that we've got a foul search on the
domain controller we should actually be
able to go forward allowing us to do
what we need to do with the server RDC
water and what Shawn brought up with
regards to the other equipment yes we'll
use serpent
Engineers to come into the post small
price to give us a health check on all
the equipment that find out what's
redundant what's not what's critical and
actually give us her red amber green
status of how look a man so tied to get
power posit say the least
I don't know if you want to add any
people turns no I might like the
allusion to a closet the server might be
yeah an expensive closet yeah it's a
very expensive closet Mike thank you
yeah I just like to echo the concerns
that the council about waste few moments
ago in terms of the effect this is
having on staff I did come into the
council offices very frequently do
jackets don't and they are I'm becoming
frazzled I think is the word that's been
used now actually might turn up they
don't know what's actually gonna be
facing them with aren't you going to
look I'm not but they're gonna get their
emails or not I was in a meeting myself
last week and one of the countess
officers were trying to show me some
information
we've got stuck there for five minutes
while it loaded I do think we've got to
be mindful about staff but it worked
exceptionally hard but if they can't
access their emails that's no good and
that doesn't give them motivation for
coming into work in the morning so it
doesn't need to be aware of you know
staff morale when they can't actually
work for me because their emails on you
could start making okay I think if you
look at three point evil and other
reports on page 63 which is just above
all said risk communications it does
mention about why there needs to be a
review because you are looking at
migration and compressing the migration
so it's essentially mentioned within the
report so you know that's how much of
that was raised that was
- Tim live it helps I mean I think one
of the reasons I get too much into the
until is the technology of all of this
but you know once you move to 365 then
it's a different sort of system to the
one that we've been using where we have
you know a a bespoke server that does
the email for the council and that
server always has been a weakling it's
mom it's not it's not something recent
it always has been a weak link for us
and you know the sooner we we move staff
away from that server and into the into
the sweet 65 there in the regular and I
think that members have been using 3-6-5
for some significant length of time
there with you know and it was it just
works you know and I think you're a good
advert for you know how hopefully will
be once the staff of homelessness
project did you want to be again you
know now I think one of the most
important factors in this is that we
need to build warm ups we need to have
more homes in the district that is
really really important we want to try
and smooth some of the impediments we
have to our building I think that's
going to be important I know we do have
allocations which are very troublesome
coming forward and may not come forward
and we need to seriously look at other
allocations that need to be move forward
earlier and also we need to look at
maybe new allocations that are being
looked at or new sites that are being
looked at which will help to reduce the
problem going forward we do have to be
very mindful of the fact that we have to
keep our 5 year supply that
be important and there may be questions
looking to allocation is especially
going back to how an inspector I'll talk
about business I am talking about
homelessness because I think again is
important to recognize that we we the
only way we are going to reduce the
homelessness is by assuring we have
social and then provided by Rockford or
from Chalmer or any of those who are
coming in to bid and the only way that
they're going to have items to bid for
is if we're building and they're getting
thirty five percent or more if that's
possible
and so if we're not building that they
have don't have a percentage and that is
our big problem and of course you know
we we need to actually get on and build
to relieve this problem which is costing
us money
strategically yeah but we don't build we
encourage others to do it but yes
absolutely but on the moment anyone okay
any others on homelessness I mean it
looks like good you know as far as
project these concerns certainly working
the working world is below budget
I think he's achieving what it's do you
know to do yeah I mean I've done deco
those comments I think it is working
extremely well I mean I was I was a
little bit disquieted to notice in the
in the press the other day that you know
agencies we're crewing about the fact
that you know the buy-to-let market was
with extremely good and rental values
for some of the highest in the country
clearly for us we know full well that is
actually a huge negative the reality is
if rental properties are commanding a
significant premium then that causes
issues for for families and actually
fuels the the homelessness issues that
we have to wait
we have to deal with so you know some
would say it's a big thing but from a
perspective of dealing with homelessness
it's it's the it's the it's the opposite
and I just perhaps equally the comments
made by councillor Ward I mean there
there is no doubt that the pipeline you
know of properties coming through major
development Sciences of significant
importance to us in in terms of trying
to deal with the homelessness issues and
we've got it reasonably under control at
the moment but you know in saying that
there is older we still have a lot of
families in temporary accommodation and
you know that's not going to go away
anytime soon but at least they're not in
in bed-and-breakfast
you know somewhere in South in seafront
and you know the accommodation that
we've been able to make available is is
much improved and there's a bit more of
that coming soon which I think there's
no advice services contracts achieving
what we want to achieve we certainly
couldn't do it for the money that we get
today ain't broke don't fix yeah exactly
again I need said was it two years in
option for easy yeah everybody wish to
comment on that at all I think
okay oh yeah it's sort of like please do
I think we need to recognize the
excellent work that our buyer service
has been carrying out over the last
couple of years I'm very pleased it's
better to the Raschi we're going back
with them again they've won the contract
and for the full value the contract
seventy thousand pounds I think that
reflects very well on awesome as a local
authority we've had to maintain that
standard of service certainly neighbor
the mythology's have enough to do that
so they think we've done exceptional
work who have maintained was an
excellent service at that value is
performing on will continue to do so
next couple years
thank you very much right yes that was
just gonna say the recommendation is
that is presented to for Council in
December and we're also endorsing
proposal that's in here in the sections
below members great item eight is the
list of major services provision
yeah this the gem says it's a it isn't
only look at the future of leisure
services in the district to summarize
treat your leisure provision in the
district is has benefited from some
effective partnership working since the
current contract was let back in 2002
you know a lot of long-term 20-year
contract so it's moving to a close now
with three half years left to go but
it's the nature of things that get to
start exporting things l2 sure we have
that we can explore future options
probably so those we can put in place a
seamless transition for the new provider
so the officers have begun to explore
those options in consultation with the
play holder for community and
and surprise the property of the work is
too effective ensure the money for the
council as always and also that we
continue to deliver the strategic
objectives to the council across the
business plan priorities ensure those
are are delivered the reports
straightforward it sets out that offices
willing to take an options appraisal
regarding future legislators provision
across the district and that will
include service delivery models a key
part of that is soft market testing and
that something officers will now begin
to look at new year basic that money the
last two as it says it's an informal
opportunity to assess the options
available and test market interest for
these for these leisure facilities
especially given that the contract is 30
$20 Tommy converse before meeting for
tests what's out there
see opportunities exist so it's an
informal process but it's a confidential
conversation with the market and
effectively enables us to sort of test
mark appetite explore other
opportunities and also the innovation we
can bring to those sites again given the
lengthy long term and provision of the
contract so currently the other part
report focuses on some key and draft
priorities in terms of people service
delivery thinking of things such as a
health well-being tragedy RSF strategy
potential target groups a table that
when we speak to the market we can try
and shape the future service delivery as
we want to see though those that those
facilities delivered in the future for
the benefits of the community that
clarifiers report have to take any
questions okay I think having had a
local help in making this fall
I think something sports stuff is coming
Dasia and some of the grants that we've
had as well they're actually having an
effect on these some excitement around
there I think it's about the appropriate
facilities where people want to use
going forward I know there has been some
investment by effusion in some of our
facilities recently which is great
because towards the end of a contract
sometimes you don't quite get the
investment that you would like to see
but it's coming forward but as to who
actually takes up like future provision
or we do ourselves or both or a third
party or whatever I think there's
something really you know we're a
beginning of that journey yes so I think
it's quite right that we begin that
early because it is you know fairly
long-term contracts at the moment
whether we go along next time or
slightly short so if you don't know yet
that that would be something those are
we discussing PLC and I think it's one
of these things where you need to have a
dialogue with those providers to make
sure that you are actually taking
control properly and discussing what the
future might look like
I think range that we've got a long run
up this this project this con new
contract date giving us plenty of time
to do the the proper investigation and
to develop our few future policies in
our direction but by its nature some of
the questions you posed through this
process will be quite challenging and
some of the proposals that you can will
be challenging and controversial but we
do have to be mindful of how people view
what we're doing and we've had
experiences in the past where we've had
open and frank discussions about things
and we've been castigated for it before
any form decisions have been made so I
would just say that when we're having
these these discussions and discussing
some of the the more challenging
decisions that we might all we might not
make we are particularly careful about
who is invited who
we're who is part of the discussions and
how those discussions might be
interpreted for whatever whatever
people's purposes might be before any
final decisions are made because this is
this is all positive we're looking to
take a new contract forward we're
looking to look at how we can best
address the needs of the community and
we shouldn't run ourselves into into
trouble just because we're doing the
work properly okay I think we need the
investment in some of their buildings
and all facilities as well yeah I mean
looking at Appalachia and that's the
main thing
the two main leisure centres brother
Clement call Riley I personally think
and this is just a personal observation
that we should be looking to to enlarge
and increase the offer on both of those
facilities and to make consider an
investment or a joint investment
depending on whom we have to be working
with because you know the feedback is
there is probably more that is required
at both of those they do need to be
seriously are great they are measure
they are in in two major areas Riley
which is going to have a population
probably in excess of 30 to 33 thousand
probably up to 35,000 quite shortly and
with the various housing we've got taken
into consideration all the other
buildings that are going to be there and
I think that needs to be increased for
that population to take that into
consideration against an assault which
which does have a large area in which
you could expand into I believe
has a reasonable area as well so you
know I mean all of those need to be
taken into consideration
I know that the various other items
other premises that information castle
wall Clinton's freight house and mill
arts are probably not in the same
category so to speak as both those which
are purely Elysium and they accounted
for that they they cater for a different
thing but if we were looking at leisure
I think that that is that that is a
focus but I would like to see going
forward that is my own view you say it's
early days really it is not that I think
is good well as getting at those views
across yeah chimney if I may just pick
up on that point cancer you're quite
right in terms that from an author's
perspective we're ambitious about this
it's a it's a good opportunity to read
regional change the market in a way that
is actually what can you deliver all
those scientists be ambitious the
demographic you have growing everything
out except etc we want be ambitious so
yeah but our challenges to the market
have between what were them to deliver
that is I've actually say early days and
we'll bring that back this means we're
going to go right but it's good that
we've silence say it's good that we
started early on this I think that's the
right thing to do so we can have say you
have more gays yes please like yeah
there anything I just like strong
members attempt to Terry's I'm five
point one in terms of opportunities or
concessions to about digging involved
for suggestions and ideas obviously
limit to how many groups you can offer
in session in state because that would
have an impact on the value of the
contract itself but I think there's an
opportunity there where they want to
reach out to I'm very sore living
example a Malaysian homeless ago she's
make mental health issues I'm using to
be clear which groups you want to see
supported in our community those
concessions take so welcome members
conjugations that discussion please
I think that's something but we really
have to think about make sure that we
drop where we can put the right things
in place to make sure that encourages
those people that can do it I know that
once I know be teaching 300 children to
swim one time you know it's amazing that
you getting in the moment so now we come
back but just all the points that
counselor with us just might I would be
interested you know is there a chance of
any grants from the NHS in regards to
the health and well-being because
obviously you've got diabetes you've got
a visa - you've got so many different
things if you know whereby you know the
government is trying to make sure that
we have some form of exercise some
fortune of good else to actually prevent
you know it's long stays in hospital
long term illness or things like that is
there a way that we can look at maybe
grabbing hold or some NHS funding or
finding this out there for preventative
measures
I suspect the most likely outcome will
be a partnership working there so we've
got that we throw some so the hospital
physiotherapy those sort of
organizations other than a concession
it's probably saying that could come
provider of course it is a registered
charity so that currently sounds they're
there any strong positions to apply for
grant and to work in in that way but we
also have to work very closely with with
the national governing bodies so they
work closely sport Essex
actually ruptured another other careers
to actually access more local funding
and for those local interventions as
well so because they because their
position that their own organizations do
yeah I think some of these don't have a
stable great
and I know that through some of the
other committees that I sit on health
committees that many GPS are in a
position where they can offer things
like a gym membership period to certain
people we cetera to tell them these
aren't weight loss and general fitness
recovery from strokes whatever create
woman and you know that's that sort of
money that I see they actually put into
the system if you like but you're
talking more about putting money in that
front if you like in any investment I
take I would like to see if there is
something that we can start with some
joint working some partnership that
actually shows that we are providing a
facility before I need that we know is
there the government has identified
these things and so you know maybe
there's a good time to actually say yes
we can actually provide for those needs
that are being positive and I know that
some authorities all over themselves and
issued the invest anything over the
spaces because it has a mental health
effects is way the good news is I think
we actually live robbery Rochford
district freedom and there's some other
areas I think the longest leaders I
think they're in Natomas food and in
some parts of us were there mostly to
their nine cents it wouldn't it be
lovely to get to something like that I
know that has its own problems but
they're nice problems to have that you
can take that forward and you know it's
that's the sort of future that we might
be doing here and of course you have to
have the appropriate two things in place
so that somebody that I each can still
we use those facilities and we've talked
about things like
Saji because of some other so-called
that's another direction that we can
take to be there too and that could be
provided as I say outside some of the
major centers or other areas that we
have available so there's lots and lots
of options in these things is about
making sure that people state Hills so
keep out of the system another thing
that's why things are very karush
between the early intervention support
connector can bring you know potential
pressures on HS okay that's not really
that's a wider effect on others positive
enema ii bricks like no two spaces the
links with that intervention through
leisure is any positive so you also
think school that's progress
thank you any other comments please I
think we're quite happy with that
so in consulting with the public
Oklahoma the community and portfolio
hold for enterprise further work and
Undertaker Bo versus it's more options
for future Lizzie service provision
following the expiration of the contract
infusion lifestyle which is basically
there's a contract that may be free
ranking which is been changed to the
Constitution which is no our
constitutional please for a crime that
because obviously don't change their
status taking over for service as well
it's Gemma no I'm not gonna report but
yes is the the the panel was created by
the police and crime so police with
Social Responsibility Act of 2011 and
it's been recognized by the panel that
the Constitution has a review so it's
updated to reflect its current practices
and operational practices and also the
fact that in October 2017 they assumed
the final authority as part of their
functions as required by the Act there's
15 local authorities and as the Joint
Committee each authority is required to
approve the panel arrangements there's
appended and it's appended
to this and I would just add that one
page 9.14 the procedure rules are not
adjustable noting rather than for
agreement by this execs him alright so
so I thought you said you had to agree
that the pan arrangements are the
functions and agreeing the new
operational procedures through affects
its current arrangements but with
regards to the procedurals that remains
with the panel itself so it's just that
that part that part of the appendix is
for noting any questions members I think
reasonably happy with is going forward
they've got to come forward other than
that any revisions in many many years
brings you up to date
so as been suggested by the server
greeting police firing propellant
arrangements are pending we the fit for
the first of February 19 and to note the
rules of procedure for the appendix
which would be adopted by the police for
a pro panel
a-doodle form part of the police for our
final arrangements members agree I think
that's the last our search engine so
there's a meeting closed